[موسيقى]
الهدوء عاد الى ساحات وشوارع المدن
الاسرائيليه لكن المواجهه السياسيه لا
تزال مشتعله بشان السؤال الابرز والمتعلق
بنوع الدوله التي يجب ان تكون عليها
اسرائيل بحسب اساسيات البريس
واثبتترات القضائيه التي الهبت الشارع على
مدار ثلاثه اشهر ماضيه تم تاجيرها لكن خطر
الانقسام الذي يتهدد اسرائيل وقره رئيس
الحكومه بنيامين في خطابه وهو يعلن عن
تاجيل التعديل لمده شهر مستمر فخطاب
نتنياهو فشل في معالجه القضايا الاساسيه
بحسب وسائل اعلام الامريكيه ربما ما يحدث
في الدوله التي بات يسيطر عليها اليمين
الديني ورفض الفصائل الليبراليه لهيمنته
مؤخرا حذر مركز الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
من ان حكومه نتنياهو ماضيه في صناعه
الاعداء وهي تلاحق الزمن في الكنيسه
لاقرار مشاريع استفزازيه واطلق المركز
تنبي بضروره العمل على انقاذ اسرائيل من
سياسه حكومتها معتبرا ان الخطر بات يهدد
الدوله رغم تظاهر عشره الاف الاسرائيليين
معظمهم من العلمانيين ومن ابناء الطبقه
الوسطى ومعارضه كبار الاقتصاديين وقاده
الاجهزه الامنيه السابقين لخطه التعديلات
بالاضافه الى تهديد طيارين وجنود احتياط
بعدم الانضمام الى الخدمه وتراجع قيمه
عمله البلاد ياتي تعقيب وزير الامن القومي
اعتبار بنغفير بان التعديلات القضائيه
ستمر داخل البرلمان وبان احدا لن يخيقهم
للحديث عن هذا الملف معنا من القدس عبر
سكايب المحلل السياسي ومن حيث عبر سكايب
ايضا يوقف شتايرن المحلل السياسي فنبدا
معك سيد
هل انتهت الازمه في اسرائيل
ان تنتهي وانما الاس
ماء على سبيل المثال
راينا ايلون في شوارع تل ابيب
العديد من المتظاهرين الذين اموا شوارع تل
ابيب على الاقل 2000 وهم ينضمون الى
الاعلام السوداء والى الكريم
بمعنى يمكن ان نقول انهم كما قالوا يريدون
ان في اسرائيل يكون دستور كما هو في
الولايات المتحده
انا ما عندما كنت سنوات طويله اكثر من 30
عاما بتغطيه الكنيسه كان هناك رئيس لجنه
اسمه
ميخائيل بالايتان الذي عقد عشرات الجلسات
بهدف التوصل الى دستور ومع الاسف لم ينجح
في هذه المهمه التي وضعها
امام نصب اعينه ولذلك بسبب التركيبه
السكان في اسرائيل بين اليمين واليسار بين
المتدينين والعلمانيين بين العرب واليهود
من الصعب في اسرائيل ان تكون دستور ولذلك
كل الامور في اسرائيل تمر حسب قوانين اساس
التي سنتها الكنيسه الان بعد خطاب رئيس
الوزراء هناك
[موسيقى]
نيه
صادقه من قبل المعارضه بشكل خاص من قبل
جانس بالرئاسه برئاسه المؤيدين وطبعا وهم
وممثلون المعارضه يجلسون الان في هذه
اللحظات في مقر رئاسه الدوله في محاوله
لجسر على الهوا التي شاهدناها خلال اكثر
من
ثلاثه اشهر تقريبا
التي قادت المظاهرات الاخيره وهذا التصاعد
المستمر في الشارع ولكن
هل سينجح نتنياهو فيما فشل فيه
الاخرون وهل هذه المفاوضات وهذا
ربما وهي مفاوضات صعبه بدون ادنى شك مع
المعارضه سنجح في الوصول الى الى توافقات
معينه تحفظ
ماء الوجه كما يقال في هذه المواجه
لا اعتقد
المفاوضات التي تجرى في مقر الرئيس رئاسه
الدوله ستفشل لانه ليس هناك استعداد او
جهزيه او نيه حقيقيه نيه صادقه لوصول الى
تفاهمات هذا غير ممكن ان يحدث
عاده في مثل هذه الحالات يتم التصويت في
الكنيست والوصول الى اغلبيها
وصعب جدا ان نرى ان هناك ستكون هناك صيغه
متفق عليها وحتى
المعسكر الصهيوني حزب غانس او ليبرمانا
اليمني يمنيين بامتياز لا اعتقد انهم
سيدعموا اي صيغه يطرحها اليمين برئاسه
الليكود برئاسه نتنياهو
[موسيقى]
دعوا الى
قوات او مؤيدين يمين الخروج في مظاهره
كبيره جدا في القدس في كل انحاء القدس وفي
تل ابيب بعد ذلك اجوا مجموعات شباب مثل
الشبيحه يعني في بعض البلدان العربيه
يواجهوا المتدهرين من الطرف الثاني اعتقد
انهم يتهياون
للمواجهات في الشارع مهمه جدا هل يوجد في
اسرائيل
شبيحه ايضا سيد الينيسان تدعم حكومه
نتنياهو اليمنيه في مواجهه المظاهرات التي
ترفض الاصلاح القضائي في اسرائيل
سيدي انا مستغرب على اقوالي يورف صديق
حميم يعاف لماذا لا تعطي فرصه لهذه
المحادثات صحيح ان هناك عدم ثقه بين
الحكومه وبين المعارضه وربما سنرى مدا
وجزرا في هذه المحادثات ولكن
اذا رئيس الوزراء تحمل رئيس الدوله تحمل
المسؤوليه بهدف
جسر هو والتصدع الذي كان في الشعب اذا نحن
نستمر فيما قاله يوئاب بمعنى الشعب في
اسرائيل يستمر في الانشقاق
والانشقاق هذا يدخل ايضا في صفوف جيش
الدفاع وهل يؤف ستيرن يريد ان مواصله
الانشقاق يكون مستمر ودائم في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي مع العلم ان دول العربيه
انت تتحدث عن سيد شطير وكانه يملك القرار
فيما يتعلق بنجاح تلك المفاوضات او الخروج
بحل سياسي لهذا اللازق
[موسيقى]
المسار الاول اما هو يحافظ على الائتلاف
بمشاركه بينج فير وبمشاركه
وبمشاركه المتدينين ام هو يظهر امام امام
الشعب في اسرائيل وامام الولايات المتحده
التي رحبت على
الخطاب التي القاه لتنوي هو يظهر انه لم
يحترم كلمته ولا اريد ان
استخدم كلمه كذاب بمعنى ان اذا فعلا
نتنياهو يريد ان لا يكون الشخص الذي ادى
الى خراب اركان دوله اسرائيل في عهده
كرئيس الوزراء عليه ان يحترم ما وعده
لرئيس الوزراء وللشعب في اسرائيل والشعب
في اسرائيل
اعطى الثقه لنتنياهو ولذلك كل الاضطرابات
التي شهدناها على مر الساعات الاخيره يوم
امس
وراينا ايضا
استجابه لكافه الجنود او المعضم الجنود
ولا التيارين الذي عانوا عادوا الى
مناصبهم وهذا الامر يخدم مصلحه اسرائيل
ولذلك انا اعتقد انه صحيح انه كما قلت نرى
مدا وجزرا وعدم ثقه في المحادثات ستكون
صعبه ولكن
اطراف ان يمنحوا ويعطوا الفرصه للتغلب على
هذا الانشقاق وعلى هذا
الحوار من اجل تجنب الانشقاق ولكن سيد
مشيرا اذا كنت غير مؤمن بان المفاوضات او
هذه المحادثات ستؤدي الى حل ما المخرج اذا
المخرج هو استمرار المواجهات او
الاحتجاجات يعني لتعرف المحتاج
ولتعرف الحكومه التي لديها الاغلبيه لديها
ان تقرر يا ايلي يا صديقي يا عزيزي انت
صحفي واعلامي مخضرم يعني انت تعرف جيدا
ماذا يحدث في البرلمان لا يمكن الان يعني
بسهوله قد يصل نتنياوي الى صيغه متفقه لها
فقط يجب ان يكون معني في ذلك هو ليس معنيا
في ذلك هو ليس معنيا في ذلك وانت تعرفه
تماما
مفاتيح الحلول او الحل في يد الحكومه وفي
يد الاغلبيه البرلمانيه هم ليسوا معنيين
باي تسويه هم معنيين بان تكون لهم اليد
العائله على كل
تعيين هل المساله بهذه السهوله هل يستطيع
ان نتنياهو كما تشير التحايل على المعارضه
والتحايل على الكنيسه من اجل تمرير هذا
القانون وان كان بعد
انسحاب اشاره
هذه هي خطط نتنياه نتنياهو لو كان
باستطاعته كان لا يمرر هذه القوانين من
زمان ولكن عليه قيود لانه دائما السياسي
عليه قيود كل سياسي والرئيس وزراء في
اسرائيل بشكل مؤكد عليه قيود قيود معينه
في هذه الحاله هو لا يريد ان يعني يصير كل
هذه الانشقاقات فعليه ان يغير المسار لديه
ان يختار طريق اخر هو رئيس الوزراء
المسؤوليه تقع عليه هو يجب ان يتهم بما
يحدث في في جيش عائلي هو علينا ان نتهمه
هو هو يعني من يتخذ القرار هو من شكل هذه
الحكومه هو من يختار اي قانون يصل الى
الكنيست وفي اي وقت المشكله تعود دائما
الى نتايا واقول لك لماذا ليس انا لست
المسؤول عن المفاوضات عن هذه المفاوضات
ولكن
اعتقد انه ليس هناك اي سياسي اخر في
اسرائيل يصدق نتنياهو حتى بنك فير عندما
يعني يطالب يطلب منه نتنياهو البقاء في
الحكومه
يجيب له الورقه التي لكي يمضي عليها لانه
بدهم
كل هذه الامور التي تحدث تعود الى نتنياه
واسلوب
الدوله كما يقول الضيفي من حيفا ما يقاف
شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا ايضا
نيسان للمشاركه في بانوراما لهذه الليله